nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
all right welcome back everybody we are
back um it's april we're back from
vacation
and i think it's important now that
we're back from vacation
for a few days before our next six month
vacation
that's a joke by the way we're we're
really back we actually are back
um to talk about something that's sort
of splitting the audience the audience
is in a sense divided about coverage of
the former president donald trump the
talking about the former president
donald trump
uh since the end of his presidency is
now several months uh in
in history i am here to tell you
that for shows like ours
it would be irresponsible not to cover
donald trump
in a very specific sense now we cover
many different things on this program we
cover
world politics and science the pandemic
and medical research
technology interviews with cultural and
psycho
psychology experts sociology so many
different things
but fundamentally we cover american
politics and there are two main parties
in the united states like it or not
and i don't like it those two parties
are democrats and republicans and for
now
most republicans support donald trump 75
million of them
voted for donald trump just months ago
donald trump's
presence in american politics his role
over the next two years will determine
the future of the republican party how
do i do a show
about american politics and not cover
trump
there's a case to be made and i've made
it myself that with trump gone
his statements need not be regarded with
any particular respect or deference
merely because
he's the former guy uh 99
percent of what donald trump said while
president made no sense his instincts
were uniformly terrible
he mismanaged just about everything that
he
uh got involved in so there there's no
doubt whatsoever
about that piece we see him as a failed
former president
trump is a former president and he's
also in a sense a guy who got just about
everything wrong
but to do what some want done
which is to ignore trump pretend he
never happened
pretend he has no more role to play in
american politics
when the republican party still mostly
defers to him
and republican voters still mostly
support him
would be silly and it would sort of be
pretending to live in a world that's
different from the one we actually live
in we don't do that with flat earthers
we don't do that with anti-vaxxers so we
can't pretend that donald trump is now
irrelevant it's also important to cover
the continued scandals because it needs
to continually be used
to put pressure on the republicans who
still defend donald trump
later in today's show as an example i'm
going to tell you
about a massive trump fundraising scam
which has just been exposed
that has completely blown up in donald
trump's face and in the faces of
republicans
they were surreptitiously charging
people's credit cards almost like a
subscription
which you might expect with a cable bill
or a cell phone bill but not with a
political
donation it's outrageous it has to be
exposed it has to be known
trump after real here's another example
after railing against cancel culture
right alongside republicans for months
or years now
trump is now demanding boycotts of a
list of nearly a dozen companies and
organization
that's a massive laughable cartoonish
hypocrisy
where the republican party is complicit
and we have to report that
so bottom line i would like for trump
never to have happened
going back to 2015-2016 sadly
the republican electorate in and here's
a way in which it's very different than
the democratic electorate
the republican electorate was bamboozled
into supporting donald trump trump ran
as a democrat it never would have
happened and we are where we are today
i would like for donald trump to have no
more influence over american politics
but unfortunately
republican voters that same ignorance
that led them to fall for trump five
years ago
has led them to continue supporting
donald trump today for the most part
so the reality i wish to be true the
reality
most of you wish to be true which is
that trump never happened
it's not reality and to pretend it is as
some kind of
protest by pretending trump is saying
nothing and doing nothing and wielding
no power at all
particularly when he's slowly inching
and crawling his way back into politics
now that it's been a few months since he
officially left office
that would be irresponsible so we can't
do that i think the
the the goal should be to couch
everything that donald trump is doing in
the context of what does this mean for
the future of the republican party
is this a party that is saying that was
a mistake and we have to distance from
it
so far they are not and that's arguably
the biggest story right now so um that's
my perspective at this point in time i
know different shows are taking
different approaches but for me
i can't pretend things are different
than what they are
and right now the republican party is
still
heavily a pro-trump party and one in
which
until another leader comes forward is
still essentially deferring to donald
trump
on most issues and we're going to look
at some examples of that later today
but first let's talk about this
incredible incredible fundraising scam
that has completely collapsed we learned
over the weekend
how a donald trump fundraising scam has
imploded but not before donald trump was
able to
trick supporters and grift them out of
millions actually really tens of
millions of dollars now you might be
saying
you told us about this david you told us
about how
after trump lost in november of 2020
he raised what was it 70 something
million dollars
with the idea that he was going to use
it to
pay for recounts fight the results
support georgia's senate candidates what
were their names i'm even forgetting
kelly lefler and david perdue
and instead he kept the cash and he used
it to pay off campaign debts and all of
this other stuff
right that's true that's all true
but a bunch of those millions that he
raised came from people
who weren't trying to give him any more
money whose intention was to make a
one-time donation
but they were billed again and again and
again
and once again right-wing media is
silent on it
republican elected officials are silent
on it they're looking the other way
maybe because some of them are using
this same scam and we just haven't heard
about it yet so here's what happened
the new york times is a full report
explaining the ruse and it goes like
this
donald trump knew he was in trouble last
fall publicly at every rally he would
say oh we've got
uh look i've got great marks here and
i've got all these polls and we're
winning everything and of course he
wasn't and he knew he wasn't
but not only was the polling not looking
good
the fundraising was looking terribly
fundraising is not a matter of opinion
it's not well rasmussen says this and
ipso says that and the truth is in
between no
you know how many dollars are coming in
and they were in trouble
so what the trump campaign started doing
in september
was to set up recurring donations for
online donors
so that the donations would keep
happening every week
up until election day now understand
that
in principle there's nothing scammy
about a recurring donation if that is
the norm
if that's what's expected if people
understand that that's going on
it's not the norman political
contributions if you sign up for cable
with
comcast and you're told this service is
75 dollars a month
and every month you keep having cable
you expect
you're going to keep getting built
that's the way it works we all for the
most part understand that
if you sign up for a gym membership and
they say beautiful
uh you know it's uh it's forty dollars
per month
and that includes access to you know the
weight room and
you expect that each month your credit
card is going to get hit
with a 40 charge that's what you expect
in political donations the default is
you donate once and that's it and the
trump campaign
started setting up their fundraising
website back in september
to by default make whatever you donate a
recurring
weekly donation you had to go through a
fine print disclaimer
and then uncheck a box that was checked
by default
to avoid your donation being a recurring
donation and then as the election closed
in
trump's campaign did even more to hide
the disclaimer and the opt-out
and they even introduced a second
pre-checked box which i'm going to show
you in a moment
known to them as the money bomb which
increased a person's contribution
automatically programmatically going
forward
when individuals intended to make just
one donation so check out what this
looked like it's
too huge i'm showing it to the video
audience i know if you're
listening you can't see this but it's
two huge yellow boxes with a bunch of
bold
text which are checked by default and
the bold text is all
trump will win win win but then at the
bottom not in bold it says
make this a weekly recurring donation
until november 3rd
and then there's another one of these
yellow boxes with tons of bold text
about trump is a patriot
you're a patriot for donating and then
at the bottom not in bold
an escalator donate another hundred
dollars automatically on october 9th
can you imagine you know how we have
these borderline illegal membership
discounts that i offer people
even though i'm at risk of going to
prison because these deals i'm offering
you are so good
we offer these discounts if you use the
coupon code better21 you save 50
off forever right our discounts are
forever
trump did the opposite it's like a
reverse coupon code it's like if i had a
60
membership and then i hide a box where
your next renewal goes to 120.
don't worry i would never do that to you
our discounts are permanent
the scam netted trump millions and of
course
some people saw it on their credit card
and they filed a charge back
but tons of people did not and
incredibly tragically
there are individuals who fell for this
who were too sick and in the hospital to
fight the charges but the charges just
kept coming
one guy named victor amelino 78 year old
californian
he made a 990 online donation to trump
in september
and then it recurred seven more times
adding up to eight thousand dollars
and he told the new york times quote i'm
retired i can't afford to pay
all that damn money now some of the
money ended up being refunded some
people successfully disputed the charges
many did not these uh refunds
coincided with a surge of donors
calling credit card companies saying i
am a victim of fraud i've been
defrauded by trump fundraising
a wells fargo fraud investigator said
quote it started to go
absolutely wild now this is not for me
about oh feel bad for trumpists who got
suckered because the truth is
they got suckered by trump in terms of
even supporting him
politically and then they got suckered
again with the fundraising scam okay
someone wrote to me and said david screw
them they were dumb enough to fall for
trump's campaign anyway
screw them on the money as well okay
well maybe but this isn't really about
that
this is about how at every opportunity
donald trump ran his campaign like a
multi-level
marketing scam like trump university and
this
is part of trump cares about his
supporters
only as far as they are useful to him
remember during the january 6th trump
riots
one of the reactions trump had as the
coverage continued
was that trump felt the low class and
sort of coarse nature of his supporters
was making him look bad that's how trump
views his supporters
he doesn't view them as people with whom
he's morally and politically aligned
who he wouldn't dare scam these are
mostly people
that as a rich dude from new york he
spent his life
trying to stay away from and he will
gladly scam them
and he did and he scammed them on
fundraising
and his entire presidency was a scam so
this has now been exposed by the new
york times
the fundraising i don't even think this
is the end
of the fundraising scams i think there
will be more let me know your thoughts
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
we are
back from vacation and there is so much
to talk about today
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about
half as much water nebia also offers a
number of shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
off all nebia products our a little old
show
is of course mostly funded by listeners
and viewers just like you i've met
dozens of them hundreds even they really
are just like you in more ways than you
can imagine
consider getting a membership at
joinpakman.com
today on today's bonus show only for our
members
my deep nose swab
fiasco during my vacation as well as
here we go now
my countless run-ins with anti-massacre
americans
around the world okay those stories and
more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com
current secretary of transportation and
former
indiana mayor uh pete buddha judge i am
not mayor of indiana uh what was it
south
south bend indiana i believe he was the
mayor of a pete budej
had to put a stop once and for all
to the absurd and ridiculous talking
points about joe biden's infrastructure
bill
having to explain to abc's george
stephanopoulos
humans need water to live which is why
plumbing is part of infrastructure
having to explain mayor pete did to fox
hosts
that electricity is now important enough
to homo sapiens
that spending money on the grid as part
of infrastructure
makes sense and if you haven't heard the
bad
faith and or ignorant responses to
biden's infrastructure bill
they have essentially been one of two
things some people
on the right have reacted to biden's
infrastructure bill
with the typical oh it's too expensive
we can't afford it what about the debt
what about the deficit type responses
that they never give when they're
talking about a republican president
going to war
never those are never concerns when a
republican president wants to go to war
then there's a lot of stuff like this
isn't
really infrastructure spending it's
something else here's an example
south dakota governor christie gnome
said
lots of this stuff isn't infrastructure
it's money for
housing and pipes on a call with the
white house today with all the governors
talking about the specifics of this
package
and i was shocked by how much doesn't go
into infrastructure
it goes into research and development it
goes into housing
and pipes and different initiatives
green energy
and it really is not an honest
conversation we're having
so she takes issue with research
how does she imagine we would improve
infrastructure without doing research
i don't know every infrastructure
advancement
in human history came thanks to the
research that was done before it when we
replace
one type of electric grid with another
it's because somewhere in the middle
there research was done
when we improve the way that we build
bridges it's because sometime in the
interim
research was done this is like when
there's a hurricane
and the relief bill includes money to
figure out how can we
mitigate this being so bad the next time
there's another hurricane
and republicans say some of that money
is not really for relief
right well it's money so that next time
it doesn't do as much damage
by improving infrastructure or whatever
else needs to be done
and of course pipes water that's
infrastructure so here is mayor pete
boot edge edge on abc over the weekend
explaining to george stephanopoulos
you know humans need water to live which
is why plumbing is part of this
that only about five percent of this
bill goes for traditional roads and
bridges you've got
20 percent caregiving for the elderly
about 13
for investments in in like the green new
deal so why not focus on that
traditional core
infrastructure well let's be clear
there's a lot more than uh roads and
bridges uh that are part of
infrastructure
i i heard the the governor of south
dakota recently saying this is an
infrastructure it's got money for pipes
well
we believe that pipes are infrastructure
because you need water to live
and too many families now live with the
threat of
lead poisoning that's absolutely
infrastructure so there's that and then
on fox news here are bill hammer
and dana perino asking mayor pete but
but
but but but secretary there's all this
spending on non-infrastructure stuff
take a listen
we crunch the numbers we find that 5.5
of the two trillion dollar well 5.6
of the two trillion dollar proposal is
only dedicated to roads and bridges
why is that well we're talking about
roads and bridges we're talking about
rail and transit we're talking about
airports and ports as you mentioned
we're talking about things like the grid
i don't know why anybody would say
it's a mistake to invest in the grid
after what we just witnessed
in texas we saw u.s citizens living in
texas
melting snow in their bathtubs to be
able to flush their toilets in the
united states of america
that is unacceptable so yes
infrastructure includes energy
infrastructure
you know what else is part of
infrastructure now broadband i'm proud
of the fact even though it's a little
outside my lane on the transportation
side
i'm proud of the fact that we're going
to finally get broadband out to every
american because we know
especially in rural areas how much
that's cutting people off from
opportunity
good infrastructure planning is always
about looking to the future why are they
obsessed with this idea that
only roads and bridges count as
infrastructure the electrical grid
green energy plumbing high-speed
internet
this is all infrastructure and for some
of the less ignorant conservatives
there's a bad faith aspect here um
there's an analogy here to the postal
service why is it
that republicans want to kneecap the
postal service it's because they don't
want
the government in the business of
delivering mail
now the postal service is a sort of
pseudo government entity but the point
is
conservatives want the postal service
gone so that for-profit companies like
dhl fedex and ups will get more market
share that you know
there's a philosophical underpinning to
that
similarly with this infrastructure thing
many right wingers
see anything the government gets
involved in
as a loss for private industry now the
reality is that it's misguided
when we talk about the government doing
infrastructure this
is not you know i know they love to say
it is but
the us is not a communist country where
most construction work is done by
government-owned
companies most of the infrastructure
work will be done by private companies
they will be hired by the government yes
uh but it's still going to be work that
goes out to private companies so that's
one group
then you have people who just don't know
what's going on they have like they
don't understand
the world around them and they think
that uh you know
the electrical grid really isn't part of
infrastructure and it's disturbing that
mayor pete
has to even explain this stuff to people
who you would imagine
know about it the commons we all benefit
from it and we help maintain it either
directly or through tax money clean
water air
access to electricity in some places
increasingly
broadband these are just examples and of
course there is
nothing more economically
stimulative than great infrastructure
better airports
so that people more easily and eagerly
come to the united states to do business
have you seen airports in other parts of
the world short of
you know there's a few terminals at a
few airports in the united states
that are at the caliber of what global
airports are
but by and large our airports are put to
shame by airports in other countries
uh who will go to stores if the roads
are unusable or the bridges are unsafe
this is economically stimulative for the
very private businesses that republicans
claim to prioritize and want to support
it's in a sense a really shrewd business
move it's called cost
externalization you're a business
you're able to externalize
a bunch of costs for infrastructure
that you benefit from they're building
the infrastructure so that customers can
go and do business with you
with other people's tax money like you
would think they would absolutely love
it
republicans should love it but anytime
government is quote spending money
they just reflexively are against it
anytime it's proposed by democrats
they reflexively are against it remember
democrats voted for both of trump's
covet stimulus bills why because even
though it was trump it was the right
thing to do yeah it wasn't big enough it
was too slow okay
flip it republicans all of a sudden
don't want coveted stimulus
when it's democrats controlling the
house senate and the white house these
people are pathetic
these people are pathetic as you may
know the
american right wing has made a big bet
on cultural issues
in the united states for the last many
years increasingly so
as i talked about in a segment before
our recent break
and part of this has been noticeable in
the total lack of policy discussion by
the republican party it's it's basically
a playbook of call the left socialists
and communists
oppose everything democrats want to do
and try to win on that platform and
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't work quite so well the other
part of course
is waging war on issues like
cancel culture which we've talked about
now
must be a dozen times and as a quick
cliff note remember that donald trump
campaigned
on being against cancer culture his
cronies
fellow republicans have endlessly ranted
about being against
suppression of speech against regulation
of businesses
against all of it we knew it was always
a ruse
we knew it was always a way to hype
people up
in order to get them activated get
donations out of them
frame the left as evil authoritarian
suppressors of speech
and it's come full circle now donald
trump and republicans
after months of denouncing supposed
cancel culture on the left
are demanding boycotts of countless
organizations and companies because
they don't like the speech being
expressed
by those companies it's hard to pinpoint
exactly where this fiasco started
but a big part of it was voter
suppression bills
in a number of states including notably
georgia
georgia passed a bill that would
significantly restrict voting and make
it harder to vote
one organization that spoke out that's
speech
about the bill was major league baseball
major league baseball
was scheduled to have their all-star
game in georgia and i believe they're
a draft as well they've pulled it
because of the georgia bill this is not
trivial
the tourism industry experts believe
that pulling the all-star game
will cost georgia about 100
million dollars now there is a real
argument that there's a good faith
argument to be had
about whether major league baseball and
others who are now saying
boycott georgia are actually hurting
the people who pass the bill versus
hurting people who just work
at all sorts of businesses that would
benefit from having the all-star game
there that's a fair debate
that i totally respect that debate but
donald trump has come out and said
boycott everyone who is participating in
the boycotts
or even speaking out against the georgia
bill and other bills
trump delivering his delusional easter
message
which we are going to look at saying for
years the radical left democrats have
played
dirty by boycotting products when
anything from that company
is done or stated in any way that
offends them now they are going
big time with woke cancel culture
and our sacred elections it is finally
time for republicans and conservatives
to fight back
we have more people than they do by far
look at this boycott major league
baseball
coca-cola delta airlines
jpmorgan chase viacom cbs citigroup
cisco ups and merc don't go
back to their products until they relent
we can play the game better than them
trump saying
we can out cancel the cancel culture
people they didn't even get approval of
state legislatures which is mandated
under the u.s constitution
and then he throws in they rigged and
stole our 2020 presidential election
which we won by a landslide and then on
top of that
boycott and scare companies into
submission never submit
never give up says trump the radical
left will destroy
our country if we let them we will not
become a socialist nation i don't know
what that has to do with anything
and then trump saying hap happy easter
this is the cancel culture trump claims
to be against
this is donald trump a former president
no less saying cancel these companies
because they have the wrong opinion by
which he means an opinion trump doesn't
like
now as a total side note this is just
from my experience over the vacation
week
trump saying boycott delta i hope his
followers do i just
flew last week fully vaccinated of
course with a mask
with a test negative test doctors were
shocked by how well i did on my test
the number of right wingers on my
flights who just insisted on taking
their masks off at every opportunity
continually oops i forgot to put my bat
mask back on after having one sip
of my water i believe the skies would be
much
safer if trumpists boycotted flying
altogether for the time being
have at it okay that rant aside
one of the things i really like about
the joe biden presidency so far
is that joe biden isn't erratically and
hyperbolically weighing in
on all of these issues some people are
saying boycott others are saying don't
okay joe biden said he would support
moving the all-star game out of georgia
over the law
and that's it he's busy governing he's
busy getting four million
shots multiple days in a row into the
arms of people which we will talk about
tomorrow
let others decide what to do and who to
boycott but the irony of trump
supposedly against cancel culture making
himself the canceler in chief is really
stunning and this is the case with
everything
we we've exposed this for a decade on
the show they're against deficit
increases
until their guy is in office and wants
to go to war or give tax cuts for the
rich
they're against cancelling things unless
it's them doing the canceling
and on and on i won't go through a dozen
examples because we've done it so many
times before
their stated principles mean nothing
when circumstances change and we will
have
more coverage of this on our instagram
page find us
at davidpakmanshow on instagram and
find pictures from our spring break
you will see how safely i was living
spring break
on my instagram at david.pacman
by the way uh about a hundred people
unfollowed me on instagram when i posted
a picture of myself at a beach pointing
out that i was fully vaccinated
and a bunch of people saying why aren't
you wearing a mask like i'm by myself on
a beach why
why would i be wearing a mask but you
know what that's their right
i'm not nobody's canceling anybody it's
a beautiful thing anyway david.pakman on
instagram quick break back after this
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
one of my favorite things is when
conspiracy theories
conflict and you put the conspiracy
theorists
together to argue over which of their
conspiracies
is correct and of course none of them
are correct and if you want to see this
happen there's really no shortage of
options you can put two flat earthers
together to talk about
how they can prove the earth is flat
they will often have explanations
that conflict with each other they can't
both be true
you put anti-vaxxers together one will
tell you oh the covet vaccine can't be
trusted
because it was developed too quickly new
technology
not tested another will tell you it
can't be trusted because it's part of a
long-term mind control project
to control the population through
vaccines it's been in planning for
decades
they've been waiting for a pandemic to
justify its use wait wait a second hold
on
is the problem that it's a long planned
population control device or that they
just came up with this in a few months
and put it out there
they can't they're conflicting
explanations it's
a just entertaining to see i have a
great example for you today which i love
during our vacation early in the week my
pillow ceo
mike lindell told steve bannon on his
war room
show that donald trump is going to be
back in office
now it's in august because of some new
lawsuit who the hell knows
but then in the middle of the same week
a televangelist
named nathan french says god told him
trump is coming back in april so which
is it a perfect show
would be mike lindell and nathan french
arguing is trump going back to being
president in
april or is trump going back in august
and of course
he's not coming back in either joe biden
is president so check this out we'll
start with mike lindell
explaining the august hypothesis what
i'm talking about steve
is what i have been doing since january
9th all the evidence i have
everything is going to go before the
supreme court
and the election of 2020 is going
bye-bye
i it was an attack by another country
communism coming in
i don't know what they're going to do
with what after they pull it down but
hang on hang on donald trump
back in office in august so none of that
is true
nothing that mike lindell is doing is
going to be going to go
before the supreme court the 2020
election is not going to be
going bye-bye communism didn't come in
and trump will not be back in august but
here is nathan french totally different
trump will be back in april trump will
be back
this month here's nathan french's
explanation man i said he was going to
win
big and he didn't win and the lord says
yes he did
and and so you have to recognize that he
actually won
with a landslide victory and a lot of
people don't get that
they tried to steal the election and
it's not going to work god's about to
lay it bare
and god's not saying uh look
you know he won big i know he went big
so be satisfied with that put on a good
attitude
and let's move forward i told you he's
gonna win big he did win big now get
over it
he's not saying that no no no it's not
over he's about to lay it bare
january february march i think we're
going to find out in april i think
everything's going to change
i see a shift i mean i i feel like the
people are waiting to see
when is the god of justice going to step
in
you're already seeing some of the things
you know on the news and
i don't want to get into too much of
that because there are certain things i
i can't really say there's a lot of
stuff i i know
so this guy says it's actually april
when all will be
laid bare to use his vocabulary so of
course they're both wrong
and after august comes and goes it would
be just as interesting to put them both
in a room together to explain
why were you wrong about april and why
were you wrong about august and i'm sure
they would disagree about why
it hasn't happened as well now one of
the things that is interesting here
is comparing and contrasting the sort of
psyche of these two guys
are they merely con men we're using
different
techniques to con their audiences are
they
mentally ill in the sense that they're
delusional
in a diagnostic sense do they really
believe
they are talking to god in the sense
that this is mostly a religious thing i
actually can't tell
nathan french seems more like a guy who
literally believes
the religious stuff that leads him to
thinking he is speaking to god
some would say that is a delusion mike
lindell
strikes me more like as a half con man
but also not connected to reality in
what may be a diagnostic situation
or maybe related to you know some people
have talked about substance abuse or
something else it's really difficult to
tell
where this is on the scale what is the
scale even
full con to full delusional and maybe in
the middle of someone who
saying i don't know if i believe this
but i kind of feel okay bringing it to
people because it's making money
i don't know i don't know but let me
know what you think the parameters are
what is the scale on which we analyze
these people
and where on the scale do you think
nathan french
and mike lindell fall they're both wrong
factually but their underlying
motivations are certainly an interesting
thing to think about
right wing media darling and persistent
fast talker ben shapiro has come up with
what is maybe his dumbest take ever and
it has everything to do with voter
suppression
and the bill passed in georgia which has
been the subject of the very same
boycotts
that we talked about earlier which have
led to donald trump announcing
counter boycotts of a bunch of different
organizations and companies
here is ben shapiro saying waiting a
long time to vote
is no more voter suppression than
long lines at disneyland are rider
suppression i'm not kidding this is
really ben shapiro's take
he builds up to the disneyland thing
we'll look at some other parts of the
clip
first jim crow explicitly created a
separate system of law for black
americans and treated them as inferior
there's nothing in the law like that
that is that's not only an overstatement
it's just an outright lie
now what's interesting about this is
that ben argues
because voter suppression laws don't
have anything overtly racist written in
them like they don't mention
black people or whatever because it's
not overt
it can't be racist that's very very
wrong you can for example
target black neighborhoods you can
target
black christians who like to organize
rides to go vote on sunday during early
voting
after leaving church you can target them
by saying no sunday early voting as an
example
just because it's not explicitly written
that this is to target black people
doesn't mean that the impact can't be
racist i'm sure
ben knows that his audience doesn't and
he's playing
down to an audience that is ignorant
quite frankly
let's continue but since jamel hill all
of corporate america should resonate to
the lie
the law imposes new voter identification
requirements for absentee ballots well
clearly that's racist i mean you mean
you have to show that you are who you
say you are when you
vote absentee if you can explain to me
how that's racist i'm willing to hear it
anyone dealer dealer it limits the use
of ballot drop boxes
oh you mean like ballot drop boxes where
people could just stuff the ballot box
or take ballots out of the ballot box
hmm the scholarship on how voter id
is a racial issue is very extensive it's
a very long list
um you just some things to consider
minority voters are more likely to lack
id
okay we know minorities tend to be less
economically well-off in the united
states than whites
so while the voter id itself is free as
right-wingers will often tell you
the documents you often need to get your
voter id
aren't free and if you don't have those
documents you not only have to pay for
them
you have to take time off from work to
get id
less economically advantaged individuals
are less able to take time off
from work to go and get the documents
and then get the id
but we also know that voter id laws are
enforced in a discriminatory manner
there's a very good caltech mit study
which found that when you look at who is
questioned about their id minority
voters are far more often questioned
about id
than white voters so understand that
he's wrong about everything he's saying
then ben shapiro talks about taking
ballots out of drop boxes
listen uh that's theoretically possible
no ballot box i've ever seen makes that
possible with the dropbox i used when i
voted
it's just a simple engineering issue
there's no way to take ballots out
uh you know the the path into it's an
engineering issue
and either ben is ignorant to that or
again
knows his audience will fall for it
let's continue it hands
state officials more power over local
elections even before the legislation
passed
many voters of color in georgia faced
hours-long queues at the polls by the
way
voter suppression doesn't involve long
lines
any more than long lines at disneyland
are ride suppression
you know what voter suppression is voter
suppression is where you don't get to
vote
now there is the climax of stupidity the
height of ignorance
it's actually hard to know where to
start because there's
so much wrong with that ben's argument
is
if there's a long line for a roller
coaster it's no more
suppression than if there's a long line
to vote
now first of all voting is a right to
constitutional right
people who are at disneyland are in a
privileged position
of choosing to go to entertainment if
they can afford it disneyland is pretty
expensive
disney disneyland also isn't open one
uh one day per year with some extra days
that are being negotiated and argued
about
okay so there's no comparison here
there's no equivalence whatsoever
second when it comes to waiting periods
for owning guns
suddenly it taking a while is
suppression of one's second amendment
right they say people like ben
say awaiting if you have to you have a
constitutional right to a gun
the day you want it you should be able
to get it okay but so
does the same apply to voting no no same
day registration is dangerous
oh and would you apply the same thing to
waiting in long long lines to vote
no no no that's totally different so the
hypocrisy
number three aside from the absurdity of
comparing roller coasters to voting
disneyland isn't trying to make lines
longer
the strategy by the american right is
exactly that make the lines longer
in left-leaning in poorer in non-white
areas
so that those voters may say uh this is
a pain i'm going home
but keep the lines short in the
wealthier
right leaning and wider areas by having
more polling places
and more polling booths and case and
point this isn't just a hypothesis
a study in georgia found that the
average wait time when polls closed
was six minutes in areas that are 90
white and 51 minutes
in areas that are 90 non-white
it's already happening it's not oh they
might do this they've been doing it
somehow ben shapiro was able to put
together a segment
that completely lacks logic and
nuance and accuracy like it it almost
takes
effort to put together such a dumb take
and these are the types of arguments
that you and i might hear them and say
nobody would fall for that
trump won in 2016. people fall for
really stupid arguments all the time
we'll take a quick break make sure to
install
the basic attention the brave
bat browser plug-in this is a way that
is
free to you to support the david pakman
show
google brave browser plug-in and install
it
a great thing great new way to support
the david pakman show at no cost to you
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
slash david pakman show
there's a phrase that lots of the most
extreme and radical religious
right republicans will pull out for
special occasions when they really want
to go off the deep end and that phrase
is
the mark of the beast and republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
is pulling that phrase out as a
reference to
vaccine passports now a little
background
first on mark of the beast mark of the
beast is a symbol
in the book of revelation in the bible
uh it has four or five different
interpretations depending on which sect
of christianity
you are part of let's look at the clip
first and i'll explain
the way that marjorie taylor greene is
using the phrase mark of the beast here
okay let's take a look
they want you to be required to have
something called a coveted
passport and this this would mandate
your ability to be able to travel your
ability to be able to go to events
your ability to be able to buy and sell
and i asked the question earlier today
is this something like biden's mark of
the beast because
that is really disturbing and um not
good
oh if you're gonna come into the
football game or the baseball game or
the concert
you need your vaccine passport because
we're trying to do a good job to keep
everyone safe
this is what the biden administration is
trying to talk to these private
companies
into doing well let's analyze that you
see it's still
the same thing it's still fascism or
communism
whatever you want to call it but it's in
it's coming from private companies
so i have a term for that i call it
corporate communism
i love that at the end it's fascism or
communism
whatever you want to call it even if
those are two completely different
things
call it whatever whatever it is whatever
you want to call it that's what we're
against
now the relevant definition here for
mark of the beast
is from some fundamentalist christian
groups who interpret the mark of the
beast as a requirement for commerce
to mean that the mark might be an object
with the function of like a credit card
or an id
an rfid microchip implant like a decade
ago on the show i interviewed
some fundamental right-wing christian
who said that rfid
chipping that's starting to appear in
different consumer products
is the mark of the beast that's the the
the sort of umbrella the universe of
interpretation of mark of the beast that
she's using
some of these groups believe that the
implantation
of chips may be the imprinting of the
mark of the beast
and this would be a prophecied
requirement for trade as a precursor to
god's wrath so yeah
anyway in this case the vaccine passport
is that mark of the beast that
a requirement for commerce of sorts
i don't want to dig too far into the
other religious interpretations of mark
of the beast because each of them
applies only to like a small
percentage of christians and christians
are just a portion of americans and
americans are just a portion of all
world citizens
who believe this mark of the beast stuff
i want to focus
on the silliness of focusing in on the
vaccine passport as some
evil thing when it comes to covet
vaccines
and there's a lot of people who have
been tweeting about this
and they seem ignorant to the fact that
they even participate in and i'll give
you examples donald trump jr has been
tweeting similarly
about vaccine passports not religiously
based he tweeted for example quote
don't let them turn america into china
vaccine passports are a serious threat
to american
civil liberties another example from don
jr who tweeted
vaccine passports communist china would
be
proud of the democrats recent push
his kids and most kids go to schools
that require vaccines it's just not been
the covet vaccine
for now although we are already seeing
colleges who are saying
you need a covet vaccine to come back to
campus those
same colleges have had other vaccine
requirements for a long time
when i went to summer camp i needed
proof of certain vaccinations
when i went to college i needed to go
and get a physical
and i needed to get certain vaccines and
have proof that i had those vaccines
this is not new this is not
controversial
it's no more controversial when it's
this vaccine
instead of others some people will say
david this is like requiring a flu shot
it's really not in the sense that the
covet
death rate unvaccinated is way higher
than the flu death rate unvaccinated so
to make it i don't know why we would be
talking about that vaccines
are required already to do all sorts of
different things
including going presumably to the
schools that don junior's kids go to
maybe he doesn't know maybe he's not
involved in their schooling
i have no idea but the idea that this is
somehow different because covet is newer
is very very silly they won't stop with
this stuff
they're focused in on cancel culture
they're focused in on
uh um debt and deficit because biden
wants to do infrastructure and all these
different things
and they're focused in on vaccine
passports right now just don't fall for
it
don't fall for it there's nothing
controversial about it whatsoever
i would imagine what 90 90 95
99 of the people talking about vaccine
passports
have either themselves or kids
uh that we had required vaccinations
which they got
period wasn't controversial they're not
even talking about it maybe they're not
even aware of it
we uh we have yet another sort of four
seasons
hotel versus four seasons total
landscaping
moment from the now former trump
administration
the guardian is reporting that an
italian restaurant
owner was sanctioned by trump and put on
a blacklist
and it has made his la life a complete
and total nightmare this is just a
mistaken identity case
trump sanctioned the wrong guy
alessandro
batsoni owns a restaurant in the
northern italian city of verona
beautiful part of italy alessandro
batsoni
was sanctioned by the trump
administration
crackdown on blacklisted venezuelan
crude oil the u.s treasury also
mistakenly blacklisted
sari graphic lab a graphic designed
company
owned by another man also named
alessandro batsoni in sardinia
and that business owner that alessandro
batsoni
confirmed that his company was hit with
sanctions they
declined to comment further so what is
this all about
in 2019 trump's government
put in sanctions on venezuela's state
oil company
called petroleos venezuela pdvsa
the attempt here was to try to get
maduro nicholas maduro
to resign the president of venezuela and
uh on his last day in office trump
sanctioned a network of oil films
firms and individuals connected to the
venezuelan oil
company but sony who's the restaurant
owner in italy
discovered his company's name amg
sas d alessandro betsoni
was on the blacklist when he went to his
bank in january the day before trump
left office
and he was told his accounts had been
blocked he thought it was a joke
he said kovid it's already really
difficult for restaurant owners now i
don't even have access to my money what
the hell is going on
now he said he was able to solve the
problem
by dealing directly with the us
government and said
he managed to get a visa until 2023
and it was resolved he got no apology
he got no explanation but his name
ultimately was removed from the list
multiple alessandro batsonis having
their companies
sanctioned by trump because
of an error now i believe this was no
accident
what i believe happened is that trump
went to this italian restaurant
and he was expecting unlimited bread
sticks like you get at olive garden
and the owner said sir this is a real
italian restaurant
unlimited breadsticks give me a break
trump was furious
and he vowed revenge which came now
that's a joke
what i really think happened is as usual
with the trump administration
incompetence in the execution
of already bad ideas that that would be
how i would
summarize what took place here it seems
as though at least one of two alessandro
but sony's
was able to get this all taken care of
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a really interesting story which
if i understand it correctly we're going
to listen to it
uh a mom was able to better help
her daughter thanks to the david pakman
show i think
let's listen to this together a
beautiful story
hey david um so i just kind of wanted to
like just give you some major props and
kind of the
changes you've made in my life uh my
daughter she's 18
she's a senior in high school she also
does college she's been doing college
for the last couple of years
uh anyway so she called me a few minutes
ago
and was like i have this psychology
paper in college that's due
uh at the end of the month i have no
idea what i'm gonna do
uh with it because it's too overwhelming
and
i just i don't think i'll be able to do
this and just kind of having a little
bit of panic
and so i um said okay well let's
write this down piece by piece and i
walked through with her
and it wasn't until the very end that i
realized that
uh the way that you analyze things is
uh really what gave me the skills to be
able to talk to her
and let me tell you at the end of it she
felt completely confident
wow because she knew what she was gonna
do on her paper and she was able to
break it down
uh and and you know look at each aspect
of the paper without actually like
looking at the entire picture
um and so i just want to say thank you i
think that watching your program and
being a member and all that has been
really beneficial to my life it's my
daughter's life
and uh yeah i appreciate everything you
do wow that is an
unbelievable voicemail i love that i i
don't i'm
i guess i i guess what she's saying is
just sequentially
breaking down what's going on and not
being
overwhelmed when a ton of stuff is
thrown at you i think that that's what
she's saying was useful
i love that i really appreciate the kind
words
maybe there is more to say about it on
today's bonus show
yes we will hear about pat's spring
break
we will also hear about mine and i have
stories of
deep nose swaps i have stories of
humiliating americans around the world
doing embarrassing things um i have
stories of
what it's like to fly during the
pandemic uh
it's just stories a lot of a lot of
stories to tell
on today's bonus show get instant access
truly instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinedpakman.com
or by becoming a patron
patreon.com slash david pakman show
those are the two ways
to get instant access to the bonus show
we will see you then
we are back we have great shows and
streams and bonus shows coming
and uh what i guess that's really the
full story i don't know if
i don't have anything else to promote
specifically but it's great to be back
and we will be back with you tomorrow
but the bonus show starts really right
now if you remember
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com and use the code pacman